[MUSIC PLAYING]
VALERIE NYGAARD: Hello, hello.
Welcome.
For those of you that are here
live, it has been a long day.
And you are like the endurance
athletes of I/O attendees.
I am very impressed that you
are still here and still going.
Like, let's go.
Let's hear it.
It's awesome.
All right.
So if you didn't attend
the earlier session
that is basically about
building assistant apps,
or if you haven't
experienced one,
here's the 30 second overview.
So this is something that
the developer community
builds to extend the
assistant, and basically
connect with users directly
through the assistant
on the platforms where
the assistant exists.
So this is a representation
of an eyes-free one
that you might interact
with on Google Home.
And this is a
representation of one
that you might interact
with on the phone.
All right.
That's assistant
apps in 20 seconds.
If you haven't built an
assistant app, or even if have,
if you haven't watched the
build and assistant app talk,
it's fantastic.
You'll be really
impressed to see
building one that's
transactional even in, like,
10 minutes.
So go do that.
If you are watching on a
stream, go do that now.
If you are here,
don't-- like, stay here.
We'll keep going.
OK, so we have had a ton of fun
interacting with the developer
community building these
first assistant apps
in the ecosystem.
It's just been great to see
how creative people have been,
how they're trying to
push the boundaries
of this early system.
We get submissions
that are funny,
and submissions that are
useful, and submissions
that are like a little naughty.
A really big variety,
and it's been great.
But this session
is going to focus
on a very particular
aspect of assistant apps,
and that is discovery.
And specifically, that's
a user thing, right?
So you want users to be able
to discover the hard work
that you've been doing.
And so we're going
to start today
from the user perspective.
This is Jane.
She is our user.
While I'm introducing
people, I thought
I would mention
that I am Valerie.
I am one of your speakers.
I'm on the product team
for the Google Assistant.
And this is Rob, one
of our engineering
leaders on the Assistant.
Back to Jane.
All right.
Jane wants to know what she can
do with the Google Assistant.
Of course, she wants
to know all the things
that Google can help her with.
But she very much wants to
know about all the stuff
that you can help
her with, right?
And we want that, too.
What we all want is
easy discovery for Jane.
We are in this together.
Like you and us and Jane, all
like swimming in the same--
I didn't have a
good analogy there.
But, like, we're all trying the
same thing, on the same page,
going to the same goal.
We're in it together.
We all want the same thing.
OK, so let's help
Jane discover you.
We're going to frame
this in three sections.
We're going to listen to what
Jane is explicitly asking for.
We're going to infer a
little bit about what
she wants when she just
says what she wants to do,
expresses an intent.
And then sometimes
we're just going
to do something
delightful for Jane.
And to talk about
these first two is Rob.
ROB STETS: Well,
thanks a lot, Valerie.
Yes, what I'm
going to begin with
is the most basic
form of discovery.
We call this
explicit triggering.
It's whenever a user invokes an
app directly through its name.
So let me shift over
to the phone view
and show you an example.
Talk to Fitstar.
GOOGLE ASSISTANT:
Sure, here's Fitstar.
ROB STETS: So this talk to app--
app name pattern,
it's a special.
We apply this to every
single app automatically.
And we-- and by default
when the user uses
this particular
pattern, we connect
right to that particular app.
So as a developer,
this is the phrase
you want to use in
your advertisements
when you're instructing users
how to start up your app.
It's, however, pretty
basic though, right?
Mostly whenever users
start up your app,
they want to jump
right into an activity.
So let me show you another
example of an explicit trigger.
Ask Fitstar to start a workout.
GOOGLE ASSISTANT:
Sure, here's Fitstar.
Let's start with
seven-minute workout.
Up next--
ROB STETS: OK, let's
switch back to the slides.
And what I showed here was an
action phrase, start a workout.
You can add an action phrase
to an explicit invocation,
and it kind of streamlines
the user's actions.
They're able to
start up your app
and jump right into the system,
jump right into an activity.
Now one thing to be
careful about here
is there can be many different
versions of this action phrase.
And so you're not always
guaranteed to trigger on here.
When you set up action phrases,
be sure to test them out
and make sure that they do
trigger all the way through.
So I can show you how to
set up an action phrase.
Now if you're a developer
that works directly
in the action packages,
what you want to do
is find the intent that
you want to connect
the particular action
phrase to and then
go to the trigger stanza.
Inside the trigger
stanza query patterns
you can list out all of the
different action phrases
that you want.
So for instance, you see
start a workout is there.
If you're a developer
that works with API.AI,
it's a very simple
two-step process
to set up an action phrase.
Similar to the action package,
you go to your intents,
your intent-- the
target intents page,
and then you list out the
action phrases in the user
says examples.
That is step one.
And then in step two,
you go to the Actions
on Google Integration page,
and you add your target intent
as an additional
triggering intent.
This will set up the
action phrase for API.AI.
OK, another thing to note about
setting up explicit triggers,
whether using action
packages or API.AI,
your final step will be to
go to your console page,
and then list out of the five
example invocations, you know,
using your explicit
triggering patterns.
Now be sure to check that
all these patterns do
trigger your action.
But this is really important
because we take these five
sample invocations
and we actually
put them on your app,
your app's directory page.
So here I have pictured the
directory page for Fitstar.
And if you see down
towards the bottom,
there's the ask your
assistant section.
This lists out all of the
different sample invocations
that you provided.
And it's really
important for discovery
because users are going
to be browsing for apps
inside of the directory.
They could direct-- they
could immediately try
the app via the Try It button.
But moreover, we want them to
see how to invoke this sometime
in the future when they're
away from the directory.
So that's all very
nice for whenever
the user remembers your app's
name or knows about your app.
But let's go back to a case
where Jane doesn't even
know about your app or
can't remember the name.
This is the portion of
discovery that we really
want to make well because we
think this can make a real--
this will make all the
difference in the world
as far as getting
exposure for apps.
So what we're doing is we're
building new algorithms
so that users can just
express their intent.
They don't have to use
an app name or anything.
They can just express
what they want to do.
And partnering with you--
I'll talk a little bit in
a few slides about the ways
you can help us--
partnering with you,
we'll be able to just take
their general intent and match
it to the most relevant app.
We call this
implicit triggering.
And let's go ahead and--
actually, let me show you
one example first here still.
Here's an example.
Jane wants to do a workout, so
she says, give me a workout.
And we actually do a little bit
of implicit triggering today.
It looks like what I have
pictured on the screen here.
We'll look at that intent, and
then we'll find a matching app
and just ask Jane if she
wants to connect to that app.
So here you see we said, do
you want to talk to Fitstar?
And Jane can say yes or no.
Let's now go to the phone view.
And I want to show you
something we're working on.
Give me a workout.
GOOGLE ASSISTANT: OK.
I have a couple of
options for that.
Fitstar in five-minute plan.
Which one would you like to try?
ROB STETS: OK, it's a
subtle difference here.
What we're doing is we're
working on algorithms
to find the high
quality matching apps
for a particular
intent, and then we
want to display them in a nice
visual manner that gives users
some cues about what the
app does and allows the user
to select it very easily.
You know, this I
think we can really
use to increase the exposure
of apps to the user,
and also satisfy users needs
much better because they're
just able to start off
with a general intent.
Can you go back to the slides?
So seeing this, probably a
natural question you have is,
how does my app
get into this list,
and how is this list ordered?
So what we have to do
here is a ranking problem
very similar to what
we've done in web search.
Many of the principles
apply, but this
is a brand new ecosystem.
And so we need to figure out new
ways to apply these principles.
We need to figure
out what signals are
important in this ecosystem.
So this is still very
much a work in progress.
But I can give you a little hint
about how we think about this.
We think about our users.
We think about
what has Jane done
in this context in the past.
We also think about, what do
all of our Assistant users
do in this type of context?
We also take advantage
of Google's reach
and we also look at what
users in other properties,
like Google Search
or Google Maps,
do in this particular context.
You know, and
together this gives us
a set of signals that we
can then weave together
into our ranking
algorithms, you know,
to find the most relevant
apps for the user's intent.
Now how can you help us here?
Remember this action package
with the action phrases I
showed a couple of minutes ago?
It's good to pay attention here.
Write out useful action
phrases that describe
what happens in your app.
You know, if you
think about these,
these are just natural
language expressions
of your app's capability.
We can use this
information in our matching
and our ranking algorithms.
Another thing that is helpful
to help with your discovery
is go ahead and if you have
an associated website or soon
an associated Android app, go
through the brand verification
step in your app console.
This lets us establish a
link between your Assistant
app and your web page, and
in the near future, also
any of your Android apps.
And as I mentioned, you know,
part of our ranking algorithms
will look at some of
our other properties,
like Google Search and
Google Maps and such.
This will allow us to
establish the connection
between the signals.
You know, so together working
on the action phrases,
giving us some of
this information
about your connected
sites, this can all
help with your discovery.
So that's a quick
overview of what
we're trying to do to make
it much easier for Jane
to express in a
natural way that they
want to use a particular app
or just do a particular intent.
We want to go way beyond this.
And we actually are working
on other discovery means that
will help Jane even figure
out things she didn't know
could be done on our platform.
I'm going to hand this
back to Valerie right
now so she can go over these.
VALERIE NYGAARD: Thanks.
OK, so I'm a huge fan of
the implicit triggering
that Rob was talking about.
But what we want to talk about
next is some kind of juicy,
like, on the front
lines, it's coming,
it's in development
kind of stuff, right?
So most of what you'll
see next is directional.
But we really wanted
to share it with you
so you have an idea about how
we're thinking about things
and what we expect to come next.
All right, so
serendipitous discovery.
We're going to talk about
this in a couple of ways.
We're going to talk about it
both in the conversation stage,
so like in dialogue when
Jane is already interacting
through the Assistant,
and we're going
to talk about it off
the conversation stage.
So on the conversation
stage first.
All right, so let's say
Jane has a request in mind.
And let's say that it's a very
typical request for someone
to ask Google about, right?
So for example, Jane wants to
know about The Red Cat, which
is a restaurant in New York.
So she says, you know,
tell me about The Red Cat.
Of course, the first
thing we're going to do
is we're going to give her
the information she asked for.
Like, that's, of course, the
first thing we want to do.
But she might also be delighted
if we give her some other ways
to continue the conversation,
especially some ways
to take action that's
super relevant.
So what you'll see here is some
suggestion chips on the bottom
about booking a table,
about getting some pictures,
you might in
another scenario see
menus or directions,
other similar restaurants,
things like that, right?
This is, actually, you may have
seen this in production today.
This happens to be
Google going to Google,
but we want this to extend to
developer-created features.
So if you were
watching the keynote
and you were really
paying attention
to this really cool demo
using Google Lens, right?
So my colleague
Ebrahim, he pointed
the camera via the Assistant
at a marquee and the Assistant
understood, right,
that this was a band
and offered some nice follow
on actions, right, about,
like, hearing the
music from the band
or adding this to
their calendar.
Right in the middle
there is getting tickets
from Ticketmaster, which
is one of our partners
on Actions on google
this is the kind of thing
we want to do, right?
So again, Jane has
something in mind, right?
She's trying to save this or
hear their music or whatever,
whatever she's trying to do.
Well, we're saying, OK,
did you want buy tickets?
This is not intrusive.
This is not invasive.
This is not insistent.
It's just assistive
and there for Jane
if she wants it, right?
And so we really want
to be able to understand
what are the actions that
your Assistant app can
do so that we can offer it
up in situations like these
and see how it goes.
We even, of course,
want to combine this
with what Rob was talking
about earlier about giving you
a provider selection, right?
So let's get to the
beginning of this video
and we'll walk through it.
OK, so let's say Jane, she
wants some pizza delivery.
Again, pretty common query.
She chooses a restaurant.
She decides to place order.
That was the first suggestion.
And then she's got a
couple of providers.
So in Jane's mind, she's
basically like, oh,
I can actually place the order.
Oh, I have a choice
of providers.
Like, this is what we want.
It's not forced discovery.
It's just contextual.
All right, how do
you get into that?
Before I go on, how
do you get into that?
It's the same
basic stuff, right,
that Rob was talking about.
Give us some clues about
what your app can do
and we'll try to help
take it from there.
OK, so that's in the
conversation stage.
When Jane is
elsewhere, for example,
you may have seen the new
Explore tab in the Assistant,
in the Assistant experience.
So if we can go to the phone.
All right, so in the
upper right hand corner,
I'm going to tap there and
get into this experience.
And this is just a
nice browse experience
that lets our user see some
things that she can do, right?
So there's our Fitstar.
And she can just
browse around and see
some things that are her
favorite, some things
some that are recent.
And if she goes
into Fitstar again,
one of the things
that you saw Rob show
is these guys that are right
in the center of the screen
here, these sample invocations
that will appear for her.
Of course, this is something
that our approvers do test.
So you want to make sure,
again, that these work.
But these will invoke directly.
So if I tap on
this, it'll take us
right into that
Fitstar experience.
I'm not going to do
that right this second
because I want to just talk
about one more thing here.
Having an attractive
and appealing
and concise, both picture
and especially the text,
explanation here is not
just for the purposes
necessarily of a user
browsing on this surface.
This is also a signal
that is the kind of signal
that Google likes to understand
what your app does, right?
So think about what
you're going to put here.
Think about something
that's going to make sense
to users right off the bat.
Think about something that we
might be able to understand
is something that your
app can fulfill, right?
Just have a think about
what goes in here.
OK, great.
And I think we can go
back to the slides.
Great.
All right.
Marketing.
Sometimes we showcase you, OK?
We are looking for
people to showcase.
experiences that we
think our users will be
attracted to and want to do,
and we want to shout about them.
We want-- again, we want
you discovered, right?
So newsletters and
blog posts and tweets
and all of the above the
line marketing that we have,
right, we want to be able
to feature your experiences.
And so what I'm going to tell
you next is one of the ways
that we figure out, like, how
can we decide who to feature.
OK.
It is absolutely true that
Google does all the things
that Google is known for, right?
We are looking at all
of the user signals
we see in the wild.
We are looking at repeat usage.
We are looking at
daily active users.
We are looking at if someone
goes into your experience,
do they appear to have
a good experience?
Do they appear to leave early?
All of these things are, of
course, things we're observing.
But I just wanted
to let you know
that we are early
in this ecosystem,
and we're also making
somewhat qualitative judgments
about deciding this as well.
So you all know that
we have approvers
that are in our
queue, and we have,
of course, a lot of product
people and engineers
and the whole team
thinking about what are
the fantastic experiences here.
These are the questions
that we ask ourselves, OK?
When I go through an
experience, I think--
I know, I see all
those cameras going up.
Good.
OK.
So like, these are the
things that I think about.
Like, did I smile?
Did I laugh?
Did I learn something?
Did I learn something
interesting?
Would I tell someone?
Would I tell someone,
like, right now?
Would I call them over
and be, like, oh my gosh,
you got to check this out?
Would I use it again?
Would I use it every day?
Did it get better
for me over time?
Can it pick up where I left off?
Like, did it do what I expected?
Did it act as advertised?
Right?
All of these kind
of things are things
that we're thinking about when
we're thinking-- so I'm not
saying that, like, we're
marking this down and then
feeding into ranking directly.
What I'm talking about here
is really about featuring.
But when you think
about your experience
and before you hit
Submit, OK, you
should be asking
yourself these questions.
And if you have anyone
that can dog food for you,
whether you work at
a big organization
where you have a big, you know,
trial and testing or dog food
program, or you've got
a buddy that can try out
your app for you,
ask these questions
to them and to yourself.
If you went through
your entire experience
and it did not make you
smile, or it did not
do something useful for you,
or you did not learn anything,
you may have a little ways to
go before this is going to be,
like, taking the world by storm.
What you see in
gray or black down
at the bottom is also
some things that we
look at in terms of
conversational hygiene, right?
So was I, as a user, just
confused at any point?
Especially when you're talking
about a voice driven product,
if you don't know what to
say, it's really difficult
to recover, right?
So when you do--
when you are building
for the phones, like,
those suggestion tips
are just really critical.
Like, help the user out.
You know, when you're talking
about the eyes-free experience,
get them to a place
where they kind of know
how they should be responding.
Did I have to repeat myself?
Did it feel slow?
And I'm not talking about,
like, system slowness.
Like, of course,
you know, everybody
wants everything to be faster.
But really, did it feel like
your app responded slowly?
Really think about that.
And then finally, there
are two pieces of hygiene
that if you went to any
of the VUI design talks,
I'm positive that you heard.
And we refer to them as
no match and no input OK?
No match is when the
user says something
that your app didn't expect.
What did you do?
Did you, like,
reframe the question
so that they felt like
they had another chance
to answer nicely?
Or did you just repeat rote
exactly what you said before?
That has a really big
impact in how your app feels
conversationally.
When the user either
didn't respond fast enough,
and so there's a time out,
or just you misheard them
for whatever reason, right?
So you didn't--
you got a no input.
You did not hear their response.
Did you have a good
conversation-only appropriate
recovery from that?
So please, please think
about those things
before you're thinking about,
like, how many action phrases
can I load into
my action package
that I trigger all the time?
That's, like, not the right
way to think about it, right?
The right way to think
about it is, give us
some things that you think
are really, really salient,
we will notice if you give us
a bunch of things that are not
really salient, right, and
make your app something
that people really want
to come back and use.
There are a ton of
design resources.
Absolutely a ton.
And some great talks
here that you can find.
And there are also a ton of
resources on generally building
assistant apps.
And so I really, I look forward
to seeing what you all do.
I'm not going to leave you
with a basic checklist, right?
So four items, four calls
to action for you to do.
To be more discoverable, do
that branded verification.
I know that kind of
sounds like we're
just checking on who you
are, but really, we're
talking about connecting
your other properties if you
have them so that
we can get some more
information from that, right?
So get some signal from that.
Number two, just create a really
nice informative directory
listing.
Make it relevant.
Give it actionable language.
These are actions.
Number three, I know
you're all going
to add the action phrases.
Like, I am 100% sure.
Do add relevant ones.
We observe things like,
well, this triggered
and it flopped,
or this triggered
and it was really
successful, right?
And as the ecosystem
matures, we'll
get better and better
at that as well.
So please be
thoughtful in these,
but really, really pay
some attention here.
And finally, like,
make something awesome.
Make something that
people want to use.
And that when you do that,
like, qualitative evaluation
for yourself, you're
like, this was hilarious,
or this was essential.
This is something I need
to do every day, right?
Create something that you love.
That's it.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]